Hello.
Good morning everybody.
Happy to be so great to have you here.
Thank you very much for joining us.
Thank you for all of you.
Thanks to everybody here who's
joining us on video on live stream,
or it's potentially watching this later.
Uh, we met, we met for the first time, uh,
at one of our camp events, uh,
in Italy if fire her. Remember
that's my kind of camp. I can tell you
that it was so fun. It was, it was,
it was amazing.
And we had,
there's so many interesting
discussions and, uh,
I think from that we had the idea of why
don't you, why don't we bring you here,
uh, and basically talk
about some of those real,
really insightful things a
little bit more in public, uh,
in as part of the Google public,
uh, within the Google family. Um,
but maybe just a little bit of an
introduction about who you are.
I think that most of the people here,
obviously a no,
you have one of the most impressive
cvs that I frankly ever seen. Uh,
you are the,
yes. Yeah, that's actually a
worthwhile, that's worthwhile.
Pause a, you're the president of
rel investments, uh, in Chicago. Um,
that's a big role. That's
a very, very big role. Um,
you are also a regular contributor and
analyst for CBS News and you're very
passionate advocate for financial
literacy and investor education.
You're sitting on the board of Estee
Lauder or you're sitting on the board of
star, uh, of Starbucks. Um, I
was just about to say star wars.
Okay.
So this is a,
you are,
that's actually a, that's actually
funny. Maybe German humor. So you are,
you are a obviously deeply involved and
the George Lucas Education Foundation,
a lot of,
lot of different things.
I could go on and on a Time magazine
voted you as being one of the most
influential people in the world. Uh,
congratulations. Um, uh, so it's a real,
really interesting, I was very
lucky to have you here. Uh,
but let's get going right away.
Let's start.
The first one is obviously a
top off mind for all of us.
You've heard me talk about it
quite a bit or leadership team. Uh,
I have to address it.
The US presidential election.
How do we move forward from here?
Well,
I think two people that I admire very
much. I have said it very well. So one,
President Obama and Hillary Clinton,
um,
I think we're both very elegant and
eloquent in their statements after the
election that the people have spoken.
We have a democracy and we all have
to respect the outcome of a democracy.
This is how the system works despite
if the end result is one that makes you
excited and happy or one that
doesn't it. Um, I think that's sad.
Clearly there are some tremendous,
uh,
dissension and a d there was tremendous
division in this country right now that
it's hard to mess. It's particularly
hard to miss when you're a woman,
a person of color, a
Muslim and immigrants. Um,
we are in a new day for us.
Some people are calling it civil rights
2.0 and while I respect the decision,
I do and I hope with everything
in my heart for the best,
um, I think we have to, um,
recognize that we all have a role in
making this better no matter what side you
were on.
And recognize the troubles that
exist in our country right now.
It's just factual.
This is not speculation.
And that's everything from protesters
who are exercising their first amendment
rights to free speech to um,
what we've seen in terms of some
of the things happening. Um,
in terms of cabinet picks on the,
like this is the process and together
we're going to have to come up with a
better solution.
And I'm not saying that with rose colored
glasses and not trying to buy the pie
in the sky about it. Um, I think
America is best when we're at our worst.
And so I'm hoping this
will be one of our moments.
So we obviously have to respect,
you said that a democratic process and
we have to respect that there are many
people who obviously, uh,
exercise their political choice,
their freedom to do that. And, and,
and in a sense of full inclusion,
we obviously do this and we
do this at Google as well,
but what would you say to the people who,
for the good reasons you mentioned,
are actually really
concerned at the moment?
Like what would you say specifically?
It's been what I've been telling
myself. So, um, I was very sad.
I mean last week we had the 30th
anniversary of our mutual fund,
the day after the election, we
were like, what is wrong with us,
right that we picked this day. So we had
all the press coming in and everything.
We had all of these,
we had hundreds of people that were
coming to Chicago for this event.
And all morning I'm sitting at
my desk weeping, you know, like,
pull yourself together, pull yourself
together. And I wasn't weeping for myself.
I was weeping for stories that I was
being told to have. One of our, uh,
women in our firm,
her sister was a teacher in an inner
city school in Chicago and she said the
kids were going up to eight year old
kids saying like eight year old Hispanic
kid sang. So I guess you have to move. And
my heart was so sad. I mean, it's still,
I can barely speak those words without,
you know, feeling, feeling awful. Um,
and I thought,
what would it be like to be eight years
old and feel that level of insecurity?
I have felt that before.
And so knowing that level of insecurity
would exist for a child and how that
destabilizes you and how it leaves a mark.
That was something that
really affected me.
But what someone said to me
that completely forced me
to snap out of it is many
of us, not just people of Color,
black, Hispanic, Muslim, Jewish.
We can go through all, you know,
Italian immigrants, Irish immigrants,
we can go through everything when
it comes to America, our answers,
ancestors dealt with much worse with less.
Yeah,
that much less than we come at these
problems with. And when they were dealt,
you know, horrible blows.
They got up and so said,
our goal right now, we must get up. This
is not a time to wallow and be overly,
overly emotional. This is a time
to recognize what is at hand.
This is a time for us all to stand
for what we believe in. And I, I, I,
I respect the other rat other sides,
right? To believe in that too.
And hopefully to find, that's my
mentor. Bill Bradley would say,
you're better angels that we can find
our better selves in this situation. And,
and I really do believe that with us
all taking that stand and being vocal
around the core values of America,
a country built on inclusion.
I went back and read,
I have the constitution and my purse.
I know that sounds really, I was
reading it on a flight. I was like,
I just want to go back. And someone gave
me a little copy of the constitution.
I found it and I said, I need to reread
it to remember what we stand for.
Then I went and looked up the statue of
Liberty or liberty, giving your, you know,
your poor, your huddled masses, et
cetera. When you read these words,
you know what America is all about.
And I am just confident that even
those of us who may have voted,
um, with Donald Trump, president
elect Trump and I again,
I respect the office.
Um,
I hope that they will understand what,
what is that risk in
terms of what America is?
Yeah. It's, um, it's a touching or
your tired, your huddled masses.
Look, I were fully respectful if
everybody who was voted the other way. Um,
obviously, uh, I mean, I had this
mentioned the story with your kid.
I had my four year old walk up to me and
he knows that he's the only American in
the family. And he basically said, well,
I'm the only American in the family. Uh,
it seems like you have to leave. I will
still miss you. And he was crying. Yeah.
But he was, but he was, but he was crying
and shaking when he said that. Right. And,
and, um, like just, it even happens
to, to like somebody like me,
although, yeah. So, um,
and I think,
you know,
there are moments and society has those
moments over and over again. You know,
Rahm Emanuel, my mayor from Chicago is
very famous for that line. You know,
you can't let a crisis go to waste.
You know,
a crisis becomes an opportunity
and we have to use this crisis.
I think we could come out of
this better, stronger, faster,
something like we've never been before.
I think it will unite people in ways that
we have never been United as we stand
up for Truth and justice.
And I mean truth when I, I'm,
I'm so happy to read and see all the
things that are coming out of silicon
valley right now about making sure
fake news doesn't exist and making sure
untruths can't be perpetuated
to become truths. Now.
The thing that I think the
challenge for all of us right now,
and I do think it happened a
little bit in the election,
we can't normalize and justice, you
know, that's what I'm worried about.
We can't become so numb to these issues,
seeing hate seeing these moments
that you just sort of walk them off.
And we're seeing early instances of this
with some of the hate crimes rising and
aggression rising and bullying rising a
little bit. And so, so although there,
there have been clear statements that
people should stop doing that. Right. But,
but still, yeah. Well, you know,
I hope from war. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, okay. Let's hope for
more. Let's talk about, uh,
but we all have to do our
part. You know, we have a role.
We are not bystanders anymore. Yes. So,
you know, we all have voices. Absolutely.
You all are best at it.
Yes. Uh, yes. Um,
let's move on to another
super important subject.
And when you have referred to the
subject of race as a conversational third
rail,
could you explain that a little bit more?
Yeah. What do you know what I mean by that
is in a lot of conversations when race
comes up, it's one of those
things that is like you, you know,
you've stepped on the electric rail
on the train car and did their shock,
you know,
and there's this sense of,
of it's a taboo subject even in this
day and time where we see race so
prominently figured into our headlines.
It's still this very
uncomfortable conversation. And,
um, I'm asking people to actually
embrace the uncomfortable,
to become comfortable with
the uncomfortable and to
be willing to step on this
third rail in conversation
and everyday life.
And I think to the extent that we do that,
we will find new ways to
understand each other.
And I think that it will
lead to heightened levels
of tolerance and inclusion.
And so even though it is the third rail,
there's certain things we'll all
taught not to talk about. You know,
you don't talk about money,
you don't talk about religion,
you don't talk about race.
These are things that when
you're growing up, you know,
there can be fighting words there.
I'm saying not talking about it has
somewhat put us into the situation that
we're in and we have to
actually, uh, subject matter
that I'm talking a lot about.
Also be brave. We have to be brave
and go there on this subject.
And in going there,
I think it will lead to great moments
of enlightenment just like now and both
sides. They help us. Can
you give us a side? Okay.
Yeah.
Give us a few examples from your own life.
I mean we talked about this quite
a bit. I know you, you, you,
you've really helped me understand a
lot deeper and they're things that just
have happened to you and that are part
of your life that are, are, are very,
very hard to understand. Uh, especially
for non black people. So, so, so,
oh,
the one I led in my ted talk that I just
have to give because it's the one it's
so easy,
is Harold Board,
who was a congressman in Tennessee,
was running for us Senate at a time when
obviously the Senate and still is not
very diverse, the a hundred senators
we have. And so he called me one day,
we're contemporaries were peers and he
said, I need to get some national press.
Can you help me?
So I had a friend who was vice chairman
of one of the largest media firms in the
world. Yes. And I called
her and I asked her if, um,
she might have some ideas for Harold
and what we can do when she said,
let me host a editorial board
for you with all of our people.
And she's like, it doesn't get better
than this. So we were, and she said,
you come with him because you're from
the business world and you give them a
different kind of credibility
than just pure politics,
even though Harold is phenomenal, you
know, and impressive in every way.
So Harold and I meet in New York, we'd
get to this building. We're so excited.
We literally,
I told this story many times,
I'm literally wearing like my
best suit and you know, he,
we looked like starched and pressed and
we get there and we walk in and we get
to the receptionist and the receptionist,
we get to the floor and she tells us,
follow us, you know, we said, we're
here for the lunch, we follow her,
we follow her through all these corridors,
et cetera.
And we finally end up in this room
and it's just completely blank.
And she looks at us and she said,
where are your uniforms?
And we were like,
and she thought we were the waiters.
And so we said, we're here
for the lunch. He's the gas.
And the person who was hosting us runs
into the room because we've obviously
been announced that were there and she
realizes we're not where we should be.
And literally as I explained this, the,
the white drains from her face, I mean,
literally all the color Janes from her
face. And she looks at me and she's,
you know, at a loss for words.
And I joke back with her, I said,
don't you think we need more
than one black US senator?
It doesn't this prove it.
Yes. You know, that this person
can't even see us in another way.
And interestingly,
if you watch that Ted talk,
I'm wearing a black and white dress,
white color, black dress, white cuffs,
and I called it my uniform. Yes.
Now it happens to be Valentino. But
the idea was to, you know,
really sort of say, how is it,
do we get so stereotyped where you
can't see beyond that story is one of
hundreds that people like making share.
It's all the time meetings where
someone won't make eye contact with me,
you know, a plane rides. We just
had something very recently,
I was on a private plane and the,
um,
the person on the ramp kept saying, you
know, ma'am, your catering is not here.
And I said, okay. You know, it was like,
all right. And he said, um, you know,
you need to go and get your catering right
now from the, you know, the building.
And it was like, uh, she does
that, you know, like talking,
finding to the flight attendant.
And he's like, no ma'am,
you're not listening to me.
You're catering is not hearing.
You need to go and get it.
So the pilots now come out,
the flight attendant comes
out and literally I'm the
only black person amongst
the four.
And I'm like,
they do that. I don't, and he looks
at me with such disbelief, you know,
it's like, well, you can't be the person
on this plane. It's just not possible.
And I, you know, we all sit there and
there was nothing to say, you know,
it wasn't his, his, it wasn't,
I wasn't angry with them.
I just was, why couldn't it be
me? How, how does it make you
feel over time?
I had quite a few discussions with
our black cougar a network and,
and they told me the stories about,
uh,
being singled out more frequently as
part of the normal security controls when
people are coming in. Right. I mean at a
higher likelihood if you're a black, uh,
you were being asked, can I please, can
you please show your your badge. Um,
I heard from them the second they
leave the Google environment,
the hopefully slightly safer,
uh, environment in that context.
The probability of them being stopped
by a cop and even feeding aggression and
being afraid to significantly higher
than for any, any non Black Cobra.
So they taught,
they taught me the word
[inaudible] [inaudible] which
is a term I wasn't really
familiar with before off microaggressions.
And I'm a hoe wears you down
and hotel like over time.
How do you feel? Like how does
it, what do you think it can do?
What does it do for you? How, what
you found to protect yourself.
Why like help help me understand
the emotions behind that.
So the emotions are very clear. One, and
I've explained this to people for years.
Black kids are taught this
is going to happen to us.
We are taught this when we're very young.
When I was seven years old,
my mother explained to me that
everyone would not treat me well.
Seven now that was also at
the same time she told me that
crossing the, the, the non black we are,
it's really important that you're taught,
you're being taught and,
and everybody is being,
we were taught how to deal with police.
We're taught to how to deal
with people of authority.
We're taught this and that
goes back for generations.
I mean obviously you had black kids who
were told never look a white person in
the eye in during slave times.
So Emmett till died because he supposedly
whistled at a white woman. You know,
I don't know if it's true or not. So
that goes back into our history. We are,
we are armed for what we
are going to deal with.
And I mean that in the best of ways.
I appreciate our parents and mothers and
fathers for doing that for us because
there is no surprise there isn't.
So in terms of micro aggressions,
we know there will exist because we're
told very early and we've seen them,
we've seen how our parents have been
treated. That then becomes not to be,
you know, defeated by it. So when you
said, how does it affect me emotionally,
et Cetera,
I actually become stronger.
I become more clear about
my place in the world.
I become more certain about
what role I must serve.
I become more emphatic about being brave
myself on top of it's like this about
race.
Yeah.
What helped you? Who
helped you? How, how, how,
how do you manage to turn this
negative energy, this, this tension,
this additional layer of stress on
a black person's life into this?
I definitely, I guess I'm one of these
people, you know, partly glass half full,
not being, you know, a rose colored
glasses as I said before, but just like,
how can I use this to my advantage?
So I'll give you one example.
In the investment business,
there aren't a ton of black women
in the investment business. Uh,
there are few.
I probably am the only black woman
chair by mutual fund board in the United
States,
only one.
There are thousands and they're more
than mutual than there are stocks in the
New York Stock Exchange.
So I remember going to lots of investment
conferences when I first started
working at air wheel and I would go to
investment conferences and people would
come up to me and they're like,
you're a melody. And I was like,
how do they know my main? And then it
very calm, very clear to me. I was like,
I'm the only black person here and
there'd be hundreds of people in the room.
So I was like,
I'm melody like Beyonce
or share one word person.
Like I don't even need a last name.
And I was like,
I am using those to my advantage.
So it's like instead of seeing it,
it's like I'm the only one here.
It's like I can stand out in such a
big way and then feel like I'm melody.
I'm like, yes with two
L's, you know, you know.
So owning it now I want more people in
that room who looked like me and I'm
working really hard to make that happen,
but I'm not going into that
room afraid or defeated. No,
I don't also need swagger. As
someone said to me once, they said,
they said this about me and I thought it
was an interesting comment. They said,
you're not threatened and you're
nonthreatening. And I was like,
that's a fine balance because
a lot of times, you know,
you have to come on really
big in order to, you know,
feel secure or you're,
you make yourself really
small in order to fit in.
And I've tried not to do either of those,
but when I've been in those situations,
I just said, okay, here's the situation.
What am I going to do about it?
And it can serve me very, very well. No,
I don't believe in standing
on some platform being
excited about being first and
only, I don't think that's a good
thing, you know, in our community,
in minority communities first and only
is something that people brag about,
you know, and they want to be first and
only for a long time. I'm not that way.
I want to be first of many,
at the very least. But, um,
you know, I think that instead of being
defeated by you have to ask yourself,
you know, for the same time, which
my mother did something genius.
On the one hand she told me what
to expect. On the other hand,
she told me you can be anything.
And I believed her.
She was like,
this is going to happen too.
I remember going home when I was in
second grade and I told my mother I had
first grade,
I had this teacher that I just did not
like and she did not like me and I really,
I was like sick going to school.
I couldn't stand it and it was
chaotic and she wasn't nice to me.
And I remember saying to my mother,
I said,
my teacher is not being nice to me
and I think it's because I'm black.
While I was the only black girl in the
class and my mother looked at me and she
says,
I never want to hear that from you again.
Ever get over it.
Life is not fair.
There was no, Oh, let me go to the
school and shake it up. Let me do this.
That near there. It was like, get
over it. I was in first grade,
so on the one hand, you know, she was
making that clear, but she was like,
you can't use this as an excuse.
Step over it, step over it,
find another way. But you can't
come and complain to me about this,
the world not being fair,
because that is the world that we live in.
And that's a fantastic message to,
in some ways it's,
it's very, very pragmatic and
probably more unvarnished truth.
And you maybe you should give a
five or six or seven year old. Yeah.
But at the same time it's
also inspirational and
saying nothing's holding you
back, but you, you know, your mind can be
the one to hold you back on this issue.
Yeah. Proof or wrong.
Get the answers right.
You, I have a quote here
that I heard from you, uh,
be unapologetically black
and unapologetically
a woman. It's not an original idea,
so I'll have to tell you that. Yeah.
I learned it from, uh, John Johnson,
who was the founder of
Ebony and jet magazines.
One of the most successful American
entrepreneurs of all time, his funeral.
So were at his funeral in
Rockefeller Chapel in Chicago.
Literally thousands of people
literally does, you know,
probably two dozen eulogies.
And it was one of those things where
you sat down and you see the list of all
the Lila gs and you're like, oh my God,
this is going to be a really long morning.
But every eulogy is better than the next
one. And it's like President Clinton,
it's, you know, just the most
amazing people. So he has,
um,
Tom Joiner,
who's a very famous disc jockey in the
black community called the fly jack
because he used to fly every
single day to do two shows,
one in Dallas and one in Chicago
every day for years. So Tom Joiner,
who's very,
very well known in my community,
got up and did the eulogy and he used
to work for John Johnson at his radio
station called Wj PC
Johnson publishing company.
And Tom Joyner said John Johnson was
unapologetically black. And I literally,
it was like someone threw cold
water on me. Like I was like,
this idea is profound. I know it
doesn't maybe seem that way to you.
And I was like unapologetically
black and I said,
imagine being unapologetically back.
I immediately thought about it and I said,
that's exactly what I want to be.
I want to be unapologetic genetically
black and I want to be unapologetically a
woman because I find even though I had
this mother to told me I can be anything,
there are times I'm apologizing for
who I am in the smallest of ways.
So I'll give you a little example.
I was at an investment conference
speaking to another woman,
my business partner who started aerial,
John Rogers walked up to the conversation.
The woman and I were talking and we were
literally talking about close 100% and
some dress.
I was wearing something she was wearing
and we were going back and forth about
how we loved it, et Cetera. He walks up,
we're still talking about it and she says,
Oh, I'm so sorry this topic
subject must really bore you.
We can talk about something
else. And I said, no. I said,
how many times have we walked up?
Two guys talking about like the
hockey game from last night.
They didn't apologize to us about talking
about the hockey game or something we
totally weren't interested in.
Yeah. And we sat there and you know,
they went on with their conversation.
We waited until they were done.
Why are we apologizing to him? And
he's like, wow, melody. Okay. You know,
it's just a little strong.
But it was the exact point.
It's like this idea of apologizing.
I remember I went to a board meeting once.
This one's small, I swim.
One of the things I do,
so went to go go swimming
before this meeting,
not one of the boards I'm on
where we were representing. Um,
we were pitching business
for Ariel and I walk in,
my hair is slicked and one of the
people looks at me and they said,
what happened to our girl? And I started
into this thing where I was like, oh,
I went swimming this morning and
this, that. I'm like, wait a minute,
you're wearing Nike's and uh,
you know,
a sweatshirt and Khakis with stains.
Why am I apologizing to you right
now about coming in with flip tear?
I know that may sound really small,
but we see it sort of time and time again
that it shows up in our lives and we
have to remind ourselves
they're not apologizing.
They were showing up as who they
are owning and an embracing it.
And so when I heard that comment
about John Johnson, I was like,
it was life changing for me. And
I said, that's what I want to be.
I said that to Cheryl. And
Cheryl says in, in lean in,
and one of the opening statements,
my friend Melody said this to me,
looks at Facebook. Yes, you know her. Um,
but it's just, you know, it had
a follow on effect. And so again,
I can't take credit for it, but I can
take credit for embracing it and saying,
I'm taking that message out into
the world because that's a big idea.
So you take an amazingly important message
all to the world openly talking about
race,
openly talking about diversity.
There is a better business angle to this.
I'm the business representative in a way
of Google and actually deeply believe
in this. But I'd love to hear an and
my teams. I've heard from me many,
many times about it.
Why?
Why do you think that diversity actually
matters from a pure business person?
And that's the thing.
This is not the people of Color's problem.
This is everyone's problem because this
is about enlightened self interest.
This is you're your own best opportunity
is leverage through having someone like
me and others like me around you.
For this reason,
there's a book that I love called the
difference by Scott Paige Scott Pages at
the University of Michigan and he wrote
a mathematical formula for diversity.
And his point,
which again I talk about in my ted talk,
is that if you are trying to
solve a really hard problem hard,
you want diversity of thought,
diversity of experiences and
diversity of intellect in that room.
The example that he gives is the,
the um,
smallpox epidemic that
was ravaging Europe.
The best scientists in the world were
brought together to try to solve the
problem. They were
stumped. People were dying.
And the person who led them to solution
was a dairy farmer who recognize that
the nope maintenance, we're not
getting small pox. So smallpox vaccine,
the smallpox vaccine is a bovine based
vaccine. Because of that dairy farmer, no,
he couldn't develop the
formula for the vaccine,
but he could lead them to sell the
solution through his own observation,
which is very different
than the scientists who were
sitting in the room with
the best training and
the best, uh, pedigrees.
[inaudible] spent so much time on a form
ever, right? Yeah. Probably we keep,
we don't know.
We can't know.
But the point being is in
solving a real hard problem.
They had this person, they'll maybe
the science, this farmer was a genius.
I don't know. But he did notice something
and, and noticing it led to the outcome.
So what I tell people,
when you think about a room you want to
ask yourself is everyone in the room is
every or all the people who wreck,
who can help me solve
this really hard problem?
I give the example of a friend of mine
who was the editor of a major city
newspaper that was celebrating
one of the two anniversaries.
It was selling burning the hundred and
50th year of this city and the editor of
this newspaper had put two of the best
reporters in the city on a task them with
doing a special pullout section on
this anniversary hundredth anniversary,
excuse me,
of the city,
and it was a very diverse city and
the special section was finished.
They threw it on his desk and just like
in a fluke there running the presses,
printing it, he opened it up and he
starts going through it, going through it,
going through it, and the entire, this,
this majority minority city had a special
edition on its hundredth anniversary,
would not one person of color
in the entire pullout section.
And he said, what went wrong? He said,
these are two great reporters.
They are two good people.
They have no malice against anyone.
They couldn't see these other things.
So he came up with the saying
that I love so much. He says,
is everyone in the room?
And it's a very simple idea to check
yourself on diversity and inclusion is
everyone in the room. So I have everyone
here that it can help me to solve this.
And I can tell you in our world
of picking stocks, which is hard,
we're picking stocks that are undervalued,
that something's broken.
You want everyone in the room
to push sides of it. You know,
we have a a democratic
leader at Ariel Ceo,
I'm more democratic than not a president,
but one of our senior most people has
a book about an culture on his desk.
And you would say like how do
those worlds come together?
Well we want those ideas.
We want everyone's perspective.
And that's cause he's a fan of the book
was there. And that's until you'd say,
well how is that possible?
It's possible because we said
we're inviting that into our life.
And ultimately I think that's led to
this cassette success of our investment
portfolio.
So it is in your own interest
to invite those differences.
And it's not just race, it is
religion, it is diversity of thought.
It is different schools, even different
political views, different political.
It's all of it because the,
even the political views
can shape things. You know,
it's interesting in the investment world,
obviously policy can affect companies. We
all know this, it good, but regulation,
et Cetera. And if you hold a point
of view very as we like to say it,
Ariel dearly,
you in our world,
you have to hold an idea lightly used to
be able to change your mind because new
information comes to you that may
force you to change your mind about the
investment that you've made.
When you hold it dearly,
you're working really hard to prove that
you can write and you can lose a lot of
money like that. Until the interesting
thing about political perspectives,
views on regulatory views, on
politics, et Cetera, can actually,
in fact you're thinking, okay, so you want
someone pushing from the other side, um,
and bolt all sides. Yes. Um, that,
that is helpful to us to make,
to allow us to make better decisions. When
you're picking companies to invest in,
you want all the information you possibly
can have and you want to try to make
the most unbiased decision
that you can make.
And that is knowing that we all from
the world of behavioral finance,
we all have biases that
we've worked really hard to
overcome and sometimes can't
overcome it all, which is
also true of life. Yes.
So talking about everybody in the room.
I mean we have our own challenges here
in the Silicon Valley, uh, as we know,
I mean we have women in leadership
positions, but not nearly enough.
We have women in stem positions,
but not nearly enough.
We have a women on very prestigious
boards, but not nearly enough.
Like what can we do about it? What,
how can we be better at it? What?
What are we still missing?
Right. Your card. We're
trying hard trying. You don't
get points for trying. Yes,
exactly. No, it's like there
are no, you know, you know what?
You remember you were a kid
and you in math they would say,
sure you're working with give you extra
credit even though your answer was wrong.
That's not how it works in real life. We
know that it just doesn't work that way.
You don't get extra credit
for showing your work. Yes.
Remember when we were
talking about sales quotas?
Just a little reminder to everybody.
You have to make your numbers. Well,
it's interesting. I'll give my own
time. I told my team this morning,
we're doing budgets.
I was sitting with our CFO here in San
Francisco yesterday for hours and hours
working on 2017 and I miss my numbers
this year in terms of new business coming
into Ariel. So I told the
team on the phone, I said,
I own that is what I'm telling
you right now. I get no raise,
nothing. I said, because I said
that's not going to happen to you,
but it didn't happen. It doesn't matter
how many flights I took, how hard I work,
it does not matter.
When I go in front of that board,
I'm going to tell them I did not make that
number and that number was aggressive,
but I,
I put the number on the page.
So if you could give us advice,
what should we do better? What are
we demanded? So this is
the point. Google is huge.
Let's just do one small thing.
What if every vendor that you worked with
you at the ask them about their board
diversity, do you think that
would get their attention?
That will give their attention?
Yes.
And we have a lot of the amount
of money that you spend. Yes.
If you say we want to work with
companies that have diverse boards,
we want to ask you some questions about
your board diversity as we look at
approving your contract. Yes. Even
if you don't have enforcement,
having asked the yes,
we would have this ripple effect.
And then if you asked the question,
apple would ask the question
if apple has the question.
But you know what the great
thing is about us talking here.
I actually run the largest vendor
operations at Google. I can control this.
Alan and Manuel, I hope you're
watching on video, right? This,
this is right away. Go out with and ask
them like literary, I controlled it.
It's my budget. Do it.
Write literary. Do it.
Let's just do it. Let's see how easy
and literally asking a question. Yes,
it's a great, great more ideas to
come on here. We are actually that's,
I mean you all are colleagues with
people throughout Silicon Valley. Yes.
And you can influence them in terms of
talking about what you're doing and what
you're standing up for.
The thing that amazes me,
you've got iconic leaders here
globally iconic and Larry and Sergey,
Eric, Eric and I sat on a board
together. Now your new CEO. So I did,
I mean you got it here.
The amount of influence those people
have just by asking questions and raising
this issue with peers.
Clearly leading by example and you've
done that with you know, your woman,
CFO,
a woman treasurer.
I mean there's so many things happening
here that are so good in so many ways
and obviously coming from behind. So I'm
not going to make this into you know,
utopia yet,
but there has been an effort and there
has been some signs of effective change.
Obviously Cheryl was here who casts a
big profile in the technology space and
she was born here in some ways.
So there,
there is a legacy of success that
you can lean on but then leverage,
which I think is so interesting and,
and I think that if you were to do that
because of your leadership place in the
world, it just would have all
these knock on the facts. Yes.
So
I had to, I had a Google of recently
challenged me and said, Phil,
you meet basically every CEO in the world,
probably the relevancy or at one
point, uh, just during your normal job,
do you actually talk to them about
diversity or do you challenge them and ask
them how they think about diversity?
And I have to say that's not what I've
done so far and thought that was a great
idea,
actually
think about how much wealth
has been created here,
which we know and how generous Googlers
are and they're giving to hospitals,
universities, etc. Imagine if
Googlers, as they were donating money,
ask questions about the
diversity of those institutions,
which are some of the biggest institutions
in the world and the most prominent
ones.
Imagine if huge Stanford donors,
we're asking these questions about,
you know,
if Stanford started asking
their vendors about diversity,
but Googlers sent on the Stanford Board,
you know, this has a ripple effect.
You've hospitals that are giant,
you know, it's not just in, in,
in pockets. You know, if you are
about diversity it in what you do as,
as you live in this world,
you don't compartmentalize this issue.
Yes, great idea. Great.
Great ideas. Thank you. Um,
well we should actually go on and move.
I'm watching time here because I promised
everybody time for, for, for the,
the Q and a. But I have
to ask you about, um,
and we could've gone on this subject
for him and we'll spend more, uh,
we'll spend more time on those
ideas as well. Um, dreamworks,
Jeffrey Katzenberg, uh, which I
think everybody here knows well, um,
has referred to you as the
Jeffrey whisperer. You just sit,
you sat on their board. Um, so you
have a very close relationship,
a amazing experience.
Um,
how did this actually shape your
own experience of how you do things,
how you run things,
what you've learned from the laughing?
Because we sold the company this summer.
Yes,
we officially closed in the
beginning of the fall. And Jeffrey,
I talked to Jeffery more now than I've
ever talked to him. And then that last,
you know,
couple of years of dreamworks as Chair,
I pretty much talked to him
multiple times a week now.
I talked to Jeffrey
Multiple Times a day and um,
Jeffery has had a dramatic
impact on my life in a good way.
But dreamworks in general,
that Board Room was one of these board
rooms and talk about walking into,
I called it moguls are us.
When I got there, you know,
one of my friends said he didn't
put together a board. He cast it.
Nathan Myhrvold said best,
and if you know Nathan Nathan
from intellectual ventures,
but before that Microsoft,
Nathan was on the board as well.
And so the board when you walked
in was Paul Allen, Nathan,
David Gaffen, Meg Whitman, Howard Schultz.
Jeffrey and me and I was like,
Oh my God, I'm the scrub. Like,
like this is like crazy. This is,
you know, the most amazing thing.
We went to dinner once a day
that Gavin's house and I said,
and David is one of my dear friends,
I love him so much and he's,
he's one of the truth tellers to me.
Like he hits me right between the eye
with truth and he does not allow me to be
intellectually dishonest with myself.
And I so appreciate that about him.
But we went to his house once for
dinner, first dinner, you know,
when the first centers in David lives
in this unbelievably beautiful house,
like one of the most beautiful
houses I've ever seen.
And I've seen some pretty houses.
So we walk into the house and I was like,
oh my God, this is like one of the most
beautiful houses I've ever seen. You know,
and I'm like, like, like a running
chatter. And I'm like, it's so beautiful.
And I'm literally looking at
MAG and Paul and I'm like,
isn't this house really pretty?
And they're looking at me and all
of a sudden I'm like, wait a minute,
you all have really beautiful houses.
I was like,
I'm the one who changed.
So,
so it was one of those things of,
you know,
sort of being in this room and what
Jeffrey did for me and Roger and Rico was
the chair that I will never forget is
I was a peer of everyone in that room.
I was equal.
Roger Enrico called me one day and I,
it really taught me about how to treat
people. We were early in the board,
having been a started the company,
it just IPO and he called me
one day and he said, hey melody,
now this is the former and CEO of Pepsi.
We manage money for Pepsi at Ariel. So
it's like, you know, this is the big boss,
you know, this is my client. He
calls me and he says, hey melody,
it's Roger. Roger have just passed
away very recently in the last year,
which was very sad.
And I said Hi.
And I remember being a little nervous
and I like stood up, you know,
to make sure I'm like just, you know,
be your best self. And I was like, hi.
And he's like, hey, just calling
to check in. And I was like,
I'm thinking to myself like,
what am I supposed to say?
You know, it's like, what?
Check in. He's like, what's
going on? I was like, nothing.
Like Oh really? I was like
think of something to say.
So he would call like once
a month and just do that.
And what I thought was really great,
he just wanted me to feel comfortable
and as included as everyone else,
he probably worked overtime on me then.
I don't think he was causing a
call meg every month to check in.
But I think he was just saying,
I want her to come into this room.
And Jeffery would always say your eye,
you know,
your ideas are as good as anyone else's.
I want the ideas. And I wasn't afraid,
but it was interesting.
I mean,
you literally are in a room with capsules
of vendor street, and this is, you know,
15 years ago,
this isn't melody today,
this is melody at 32 you know,
walking into a room.
So it was something that was a gift.
And so I give Jeffrey a lot of credit for
that because I saw what it was like to
be a peer,
which was so different than all we're
talking about when you're in rooms with
microaggressions where people
make you feel differently. Yes.
So then when Roger was no longer chair,
Nathan went to Jeffrey and said melody
as chair. And I was like shocked.
He's like, she's earned it. And
she's the person who should be chair.
And she's the one who we have the most
faith and confidence in. So again,
it's the people in the room, you're
thinking, well, they've picked me. No,
I did always made sure I did all
my homework. I showed up, you know,
really ready to go, et
cetera. But from Jeffrey,
I learned about what it was like to see
people for not anything that comes in
packaging purely on ideas
and the merit of those ideas,
purely not to be an influence
about anything else. And two,
and then Jeffrey and I had a constant
conversation and what I joke with with
Jeffery,
I said,
I am Jeffery's head deflator of gravity
boots because this is a guy with a
million ideas a minute.
And sometimes I've just take a pen,
a pen and stick it in and his
head just Tryna shrivels up.
And other times I have to like keep
them down on the earth like Jeffrey,
stay with us so we're losing you.
Um,
and it became this wonderful working
relationship that Greg gave me. Great Joy.
I was, I was so sad when dreamworks
was over because I loved the work.
Talking relationships.
You were raised by a single mother,
Dorothy. Um, talk a little
bit about this experience.
There was something very special about it.
Well, my mom was, I was one of six kids.
I'm really young relative to my siblings.
My oldest sister is more
than 20 years older than me.
My siblings continually told me that I
was left on the doorstep and that really
wasn't their sister.
Um,
and that's very weird when you're like
five years old and the person telling you
is 27. Um, uh,
but ultimately they were
great. Um, five girls,
one boy and my mother,
I already given you a sense of this
brutal pragmatism that she had. Um,
she was very impractical in every
way you could possibly imagine.
Like she would buy Easter dresses
instead of pay the phone bill.
So we always got evicted and our lights
got disconnected and our phone got
turned off all the time.
Our cars got repossessed.
And that was talking about
that sense of insecurity.
I felt that I think about when I think
of that Hispanic kid thing saying,
so you have to move. Um, but
at the same time she was great.
And one of the things that I think that
has come through with my mother is that
she did give me great optimism
and hope I was never downtrodden.
I may not have had things and I may have
had some serious setbacks along the way.
Um, but I was not down tried and she
did not have, let me accept that idea.
And you know, I once heard Magic
Johnson say, um, you can be poor,
but you don't have to have poor dreams.
And I was like,
I think my mother sort of intuitively
understood that, you know,
during some of our more challenging time,
she always had these fantastical dreams.
She was totally unrealistic
and a lot of ways
to share those dreams with, oh
my God, my mother, my mother was
blind at the end of,
of starting when I was in high school.
She went blind every single day.
My, I mean, my mother was blind,
but she would not acknowledge it. And
she, every single day she was like, oh no,
I'm going to be healed now. I mean,
she would literally, she was blind.
She was like, no, I'm going to
wake up tomorrow and see tomorrow.
I'm going to be able to see
tomorrow, every day. Like,
what kind of faith is that?
Right? Every day, you know,
she was blind from when I was in
high school until she died, you know,
four years ago. So that's
a long time everyday, oh,
tomorrow I'm going to be able to see.
And we're just like, no. But you know,
you don't want to take that away from
someone, you know, at the same time.
Hope and faith, I'm very
important. You know,
that you don't play around with
someone's optimism. And I learned that.
That's inspiring.
Okay. We want to go to the questions. Um,
we just to just end on a
lighthearted question. You, you're,
you're married to a, let's
say a star wars fan. Um,
uh, you're, you're actually, um, I
always say I'm married to Yodas Dad,
dad married to so and so. Um, how,
how it doesn't go backwards. How does
this, I mean, how does this feel?
You actually, um, I, um, when
it was sold the last time,
I actually realized that you're actually
a character in one of the movies. Um,
not the movies, the television. Yes, yes,
yes. That's, yes, that's, that's correct.
Talk to us a little bit about how
this, how this fields, and by the way,
there's a big value piece in this
as well as well.
And,
and that's something I
actually only realized by
interacting with you and George
A. Little bit more is just talk to us a
little bit about like this part of your
life.
Well,
I have to say it's a crazy part in
so many ways and it's fantastic.
Um, George is iconic, you know,
he's known around the world
wherever we go, you know,
literally we walked down the
street, people are wearing
star wars tee shirts. Um,
we, um, it's a part of
society in the world,
you know, the sayings, the, you
know, there's so many examples. Um,
and we'd literally, we joke and bring them
into our lives all the time. You know,
it's just so funny. Um, which
is really, really great. Um,
my husband knows I'm always like a
hawk around like commuting desserts and
things like that, cause they
say, you know, he's much
older than me and I was like,
I need 20 years, so I've got to get
you to live 20 years. So they're like,
he'll have an ice cream cone.
And he's like,
this is not the ice cream you're
looking for. You know? And he's like,
starts to of convinced me
that I didn't see a meeting,
nice cream or would have you.
But the thing you know that he,
when he set out to write star wars,
he wrote it to teach 12 year
old girls and boys values.
And it's a story about
following light versus darkness.
And he says very clearly that
in the movies the darkness
can give you more power.
The dark side can have more power.
We've seen that with the emperor and
Darth Vader and it can et cetera.
But the light will bring you more joy.
And he's very,
very clear about that in life of the
pursuit of joy over power and the,
the certainly the pursuit of joy over
pleasure. You know, he talks about,
and he's told me a lot about pleasure
being fleeting and joy being permanent,
that when you seek pleasure,
you always have to up the ante,
which is why drug addicts become drug
addicts. They need another level.
We see that with people with great wealth.
It's like another car or another boat,
another house. You're always trying
to up the ante. And he's like,
the thing about life,
it's the pleasure that stays with you
don't need to up the ante on pleasure
because it's in you watching a child
grow up or smile or some of these things
that are really just
sort of deeply in you,
memories that you know that
will bring you joy forever.
And so that's been something that,
especially in this time today,
I've been thinking a lot about are
we going to go to the darkness?
Are we going to go to the light?
And the delight,
the darkness may being bring power.
And we're certainly seeing that.
But the light will bring
joy. You know, I still,
if you don't even like Barack Obama,
you can't look at him and not see light.
You may not like a thing he says,
a policy that he has,
but there's an elegance and lightness
to him that is inspiring that you would
like your child to have. And so
I think about that. Not a lot.
And it's not about he, he lifts us us
as opposed to putting us down. Yeah.
And you know,
again,
that is something that means a lot to
me and it means a lot to me now that I
have a three year old, I want those
examples and George tapped into that.
That's why it's gone on for 40 years.
That's why people keep going back to
the stories because there's such depth
there to them and he has,
he's teaching us in those movies.
He's teaching us a lot. And you
know, I tell people, I've learned,
I know more stories.
There's facts and you could possibly ever
imagine I'd probably have the largest
collection of star wars tee shirts
of any person walking, watching,
walking the earth. Because
every day, every week,
George gets everything that has ever been
made with star wars on it once a week
that week.
So the archives are gigantic and he
brings home all the things that he thinks
will like. But in, in, in doing this,
he's explained so many things to me
about what he was thinking. For example,
with Yoda,
Yoda talks backwards because he said he
was trying to teach 12 year olds and if
Yoda said everything he says
directly it was preachy.
So he said if I turned it around the
kid had to listen and untangle it.
So it forced them to listen in a different
way. So when you hear do or do not,
there is no try. It doesn't offend you.
Yeah. Versus how it may have come across.
If you say, you know, try, yeah,
you don't think about this level of
depth and thinking at the time this was
basically created,
well there's nothing accidental and
star wars. That's the thing about it,
and this is the piece
which I find fascinating,
like Yoda is the dimensions of a two year
old. And the reason that that is true,
the face we are cutest.
A human being is the cutest they ever
are between the ages of two and three.
And that is actually for a reason.
They say you have the terrible twos.
This has been studied.
George has lots of facts on that.
Children are so awful between two and
three that if they weren't cute we would
kill them.
And when you think back to caveman times,
so they made them so cute
so you couldn't kill them.
So he said he actually intentionally made
Yoda all the dimensions of a two year
old. He's an 800 year old, two year old
to make him so cute. All of his eyes,
the spatial dimensions,
nothing is accidental. Nothing.
He's like thought it through to another
level that you would never imagine. Yeah.
Okay. I'll be cute. Does of two year
olds. We have a few minutes left.
Maybe we can go a couple of
minutes over, uh, on the question.
So I want to get started right away. We
have our doors here. Uh, let's start.
Animated movies are lagging behind
as far as diversity is concerned,
not that real movies are perfect.
Is this something you
discussed in board meetings?
Do the hero's ethnic ethnicity and gender
have an impact on the revenues and so
on?
I love this question because I
have a real life story on that.
So we're in the dreamworks board meeting.
Jeffrey knows I tell this story.
So I'd been very open about it
and we saw the movie mega mines,
which was a dreamworks movie,
cause we would watch the movies in
the board meetings all the time.
So we watched mega mines, we come out
of the theater, we're in the boardroom.
And he always say like, well what
do you do? Think of the movie.
So I wait for everyone. I'm sitting
around waiting, waiting, waiting.
And finally I'm like, the city
was metropolis. He's like, yes.
I was like,
the only person of color was blue
in the entire movie.
There was one scene where the hero kiss
a baby that's black. And I was like,
it didn't even have a black parent
that went with that. And I was like,
there are no people of Color
in this movie. None. None.
Except for the, you
know, the main character.
So Jeffrey sort of a couple of people
pile on and then the meeting is over.
So I get a call from Jeffery when
I land in Chicago and he's like,
I need you to come to La and have
lunch with me. And I was like,
come back to la now.
We don't know each other well at all.
It's early in my tenure at dreamworks.
And I said, okay, I'll come back.
So I get back and we're sitting in this,
the grill in Los Angeles and he
looks at me and he's like, you know,
you really embarrassed me in that
board meeting and I'm thinking like,
get ready for a fight. You
know, like in my mind I'm like,
like in my mind I'm like this.
And he's like,
and it will never happen again.
I'm mortified.
I didn't see it.
It will never happen
again, ever. And he's like,
that's why you have to be in the room.
And I said back to us,
everyone in the room, right?
And he said, I didn't see it.
So interestingly in tip,
uh,
the mood, the character
tip in, um, oh my God,
the name of the movie just
went in and out of my head.
Rihanna is the main character. Um, Oh God,
it'll come to me on one
second. Sorry. Yeah,
it's Google home. Excuse me.
Home. So thank you, Jamie. Clara.
So in home, Rihanna is the
first mixed race protagonist,
main character j lowest her mother,
and it's very clear of father's
black based upon her hair.
And so we don't see her
father in the movie.
And so Rihanna has obviously
this huge following.
We do the movie and all of these people
start writing Jeffery these letters and
these letters are things like,
I just want you to know my child has
never seen a character in a movie that was
the main character, animate it
with hair that looked like hers.
My child has never seen an animated movie
with a main character where the child
was participant Mac. My child
does. And so Jeffrey was like,
melody is the reason that we did this
because she's the one who told us mega
mine nest and we want it to push this.
And the thing was,
which I explained to you know that it
didn't take rocket science to figure out
again as this in your own best interest
African Americans and Hispanic overindex
and movie going.
We do.
And so there are certain things where we
over index in a big way and movie going
as one. And I just said,
this is one of these things,
this is not only feels great and
it's wonderful and the movie,
it was this tremendous success,
but it's also great that we've inspired
all these people because they see people
who look like them when most often
than not, that is not the case.
Now we've had the princess and the frog.
We had will Smith as a main
character and one of our movies,
I mean we've had a lot of diversity
but this was one of the, you know,
the most direct and outward signs of that.
And that was really invigorating.
Is that enough? No. So
we need to do a lot more,
but that certainly was one where that
was a good example on a great start. Yes.
Yes. We have a live question.
Thank you. Hi Melodie.
Thank you so much for being here and um,
on behalf of Google, I think you just,
you're such an inspiration
and what a powerful message,
and I know the room is not totally
full because it is the Friday before
thanksgiving,
so apologies on that,
but everyone is on the live stream and
we will absolutely share it on demand to.
Thank you so much for your time.
My question actually is about your two
or three year old beautiful daughter,
Everest and thanks to your great mother
and all of the values and messages she
instilled in you.
What is that hopeful optimism that
you're planning to instill in her as she
becomes a beautiful lady?
Well,
the most important thing that I believe
in is making sure she's a good person.
I think that trumps everything. It's
not what you do, what you achieve,
you know, anything else, how successful
she is. I just want a good person.
I want a person who is empathetic,
who has concerned for others.
My child that Warren Buffett has a
saying that if you're born in America,
you've won the birth lottery.
My child won the birth lottery in America.
She has two extraordinarily
devoted and successful parents.
She has a life that any person
would dream auth in every way,
a life that I could never
have even remotely understood.
She has devoted CareKit caretakers.
My child does now fluent because we
started when she was born in Mandarin,
so we started teaching our Mandarin.
She goes to a Chinese immersion
school with no English, so she's,
she's been to China three times
and she's three. You know,
these are things that are just not
normal. Right? But at the same time,
what I have told people,
I have very clear and high expectations
of the contribution that she must make
and give back to society. And people say
to me, you can't burden her with that.
I said,
hell yes I can.
Because she got way more
than her fair share.
She will never wake up in the morning
wondering about food or clothing or
shelter. I've been there and I don't
want to put all of that on her,
but I want her to be aware of what that
is like as it relates to other people.
One day she came to us,
she would go to the Chinese American
Service League in Chicago to play with the
kids starting when she was one years
old and they're all immigrants.
Children who were the parents would go
to learn how to assimilate in America and
the kids would be put in a room
to play together. And Everest,
the little brown child was the only
non Chinese child in the room. Beige,
she's not quite brown as my husband
said when she was born. What happened?
I already ordered a brown
one. Um, but anyway, she um,
she goes to this class one day,
she comes home,
she's two years old and she starts
picking up her toys and she starts putting
them at the front door in our
apartment in Chicago. And we said,
what are you doing?
And she said,
we have to take these toys to school
now in broken sentence. You know,
she can't even form a full sentence
at that age. And so we said, she said,
the other kids need the toys. And
I was like, that's the kid I want.
That is the kid I want. Where she saw
they were playing with broken toys. She,
we were, she was born, we got 600 baby
gaps. Even though I told people no gaps,
600 someone sent us 2000 bucks,
2000 and so I said to,
I said it was such an Mba,
we got literally like 30 copies
of goodnight moon literally.
So we're sending them the
hospitals and everything.
So I want her to understand like this is
too much. So when she started putting,
they get her and she's like,
their toys are broken.
I was like that is what we have to
instill in her for the rest of her life
because she has more than her fair share
and that will be where I would be most
proud of her if she has that goodness in
her and she sees now they say bilingual
children are naturally more empathetic
because they understand when someone
doesn't understand, which was part of
the reason I wanted her to be bilingual.
That was the start to this life of empathy
that I hope that she has not sympathy.
Empathy.
Oh,
can we go on for a few more
minutes? How are you guys?
Okay. All right. Okay, great.
Thank you.
Um,
you've been actively engaged in financial
literacy with all of the new apps
tools available today.
Do you see more opportunity for women,
minorities to dramatically improve
their financial literacy? And if so,
are you involved in any
interesting projects in this area?
Yes, I think this is, we're
at a precipice of a moment.
The thing about America is we are
not financially literate, literate.
That's everyone.
You can go to high school in America
today and take wood shop or auto and not a
class on investing, which always leads
me to ask people who whittles, right?
Who is cleaning their own
carburetor when you can't.
The class on investing in America.
So all of us,
even if you've gone to the best schools,
you may have taken corporate
finance at an Ivy League school,
but you didn't take a class on the
stock market and investing most likely.
So we hand people the keys to their
financial future when they go to work at
their first job because we tell them,
here's your 401k plan,
pick your investment options.
And no one taught you how to drive.
So I said it's the equivalent of handing
literally the keys to our core bat to a
16 year old with a bottle of Jack Daniels
and no driver's license and say have a
good time.
Like it has dramatic implications for
your life as well as your children and
your parents. If you help support
them, it's, it's a big damn deal.
So as a result of that,
I've been an evangelist on this
idea of financial literacy.
That is why I wake up when I'm
out here on the west coast,
I had to go to CBS at like they come to
blow dry my hair like one in the morning.
My husband is literally like,
you have a night shift.
Literally because I'm getting up to
go to dcbs and by 4:00 AM in the city.
And people say, well why do you do
it? I don't do it for publicity.
I don't do it for money.
I do it because it's my opportunity
to educate people about money.
And I see that as part of my calling
in life because I've gotten this
opportunity to understand. And because
we don't learn about this in school,
the good news is that there are
more tools than ever before.
Four one k plans have gotten so much
better at providing financial information
of people would take advantage of
it. I just, uh, actually invested in,
I say this not because of it's an
investment. I hope it works out,
but that's not the reason
I'm giving them a plug.
I've invested in this company
called Ellevest, which is a, um,
Robo advisor targeting women,
which I think one,
the name is great and Sallie Krawcheck
who started the company who came off of
Wall Street, uh, first alliance
Bernstein, then Bank of America.
She is fantastic and I think she's put
together something really special to
appeal to women.
Um,
I've been here and I've gone to talk to
Sal Kahn about what he's doing when it
comes to financial literacy. So I,
and he has some great things, uh,
at the Khan Academy that will help people
and he's doing great things with Bank
of America in that regard.
So I do think there are more
opportunities than ever before.
But I do think also we have
to understand as a society,
we hold the keys to our
own financial future.
The days of working for a company for 30
years and require retiring with a gold
watch and a secure pension are over.
The average American will have
11 jobs in their lifetime.
And even if you have
done right by yourself,
if you've saved and
invested appropriately,
if you're maxing out with
your four one k plan,
you have may have someone in another
office or the next cube that has done
nothing.
And it's because of that,
they will be a burden on society
and ultimately affect you.
So this is everyone's problem.
And the one thing that we can do about it,
because we'd say an area,
one of our famous sayings,
we have admired this problem
long enough on this one.
You can take this cause into your own
life demanding your children's schools,
your, your, your nephews or
nieces, your God children's,
that they ultimately have financial
literacy programs in those schools.
And that ultimately that we start to
develop a language around investing for
young people so that when they hear about
the Nasdaq, the Dow and the s and p,
it's not a foreign language to them
and that they ultimately become more
comfortable and fluid in these ideas
of a saving and investing which have
profound implications for our society.
Anyone who thinks this is
social security as a safety net,
especially the people of this generation
in this audience and in this company,
millennials,
it's a safety net with holes.
If you're under the age of 40 it is a
question of what the social security will
look like and not to mention the average
social security check in America today
is $1,100 that is not when any of us
would consider the golden years and yet 80
million Americans ate oh are currently
working in companies where there is no
retirement plan for them and so
security will be their only option.
By the way, if there's anything
we can do to help more,
especially in the youtube side,
we work closely with the
Canada Academy and so on.
Maybe there's some interesting ideas
because that's obviously a great medium to
um, uh, to, to display and show some
of this information. Let's do, uh,
let's do one more question here. Just
looking at time. Uh, it's so important.
Children grow into leaders
that are accepting of all,
I have a biracial niece that is
eight years old and has already felt
discrimination. Do you have a
recommendation for a book or something?
Children of all types,
especially girls can read that
emphasizes leadership and equality.
This is hard one.
Obviously I have a biracial child as
well and I always tell my husband,
he is always kind of reminding, trying
to remind me. He's like, you know,
she's part white and I'm like in
America when you have any black in you,
you're black.
That's just how you're seeing.
You're not seeing as part white people
don't look at Barack Obama and say he's
part white. They said we have a black
president. And so, um, again, in the,
in the spirit of truth,
even though my child, we,
my husband told her that Baba,
she calls him Bob Bob because it's Chinese
for Father Baba is a white and Mama
is black. And he said Everest is
black and white. And she said,
and Mandarin
because she thinks she's parked Chinese.
Her favorite food is me, fat rice. And um,
so we have a long way to go before her.
She really does understand that
she's part black and white.
I've got to get some sweet potato pie to
her or something, a bean pie. But anyway,
she, um, I think the one thing we
can do, especially for girls, I just,
when I was a kid,
I read all of these.
There were these little red books
in my library at school. Um,
where I grew up in these little red book.
We're biographies of
famous people and they had,
they had literally had books on any
Oakley and Louisa may Alcott and Harriet
Tubman and all these people.
And I had this desire before I graduated
from eighth grade to read every
biography that was on the shelf.
And there were a couple hundred of them.
And reading about people makes a huge
difference in your life. You know,
when you can read about their
struggles and what they went through.
I don't think there's any one book. I
think it's just the idea of reading about,
uh, individuals, um, that makes
a huge difference in inspires.
And so I, there's no magic bullet on
this. Knowledge is power and information.
We all know that. And hopefully the, in
reading about the struggles of others,
she'll get the confidence to the eight
year old biracial niece to take this
world on,
uh,
with great energy and enthusiasm
and confidence. But you know, it's,
it's, it's uh, it's not,
uh, one thing, uh, one book,
a one conversation.
It's a,
it's a narrative and that narrative
has to go on for life. I mean,
I still feel like I have
to be infused with that.
When I was having my hard time last week,
it was someone else who told me,
think about your ancestors.
You're not in a field picking cotton.
You didn't give birth to Everest and
a field and have to get back to work.
That's the truth of what happens.
So get over yourself and um,
you know,
I have great optimism for the
young kids that are out there,
but what I tell people do not tell them
not to see race, tell them to embrace it.
You know, I think that's just as
important. They can't look beyond it.
All these people talk about how
they're colorblind and I, you know,
as you give real life examples,
I had a friend who worked at MTV and they
said they did a survey of millennials
and they asked them all these attitudinal
questions and they were all like,
spot on, you know, in terms
of views about things.
Just lined up exactly with
what you want with society.
And then the ask them what would they do?
Would you date a black girl,
the college football, uh,
captain? He was like, no.
And I was like,
of course I know that because the black
girl in all white schools doesn't have
dates. I was one of them.
That's just what happens. So,
you know, let's, let's not
have them in this vacuum of,
I don't even see that
because it's not real.
That's not the reality that we live in.
Let's embrace those differences.
And so telling your eight year old niece,
making sure she understands
where she comes from,
who she is and all the people
are out there who are like her,
who've done extraordinary things
and Barack Obama is one, you know,
one of my heroes. It doesn't
have to be yours. I, you know,
we all have a right to our different
ups differences of opinion,
but there's some people out there who,
you know,
are pretty remarkable and have been
pretty remarkable who don't live anymore.
This is so interesting. Are you okay
to go on for a few more minutes? Yeah,
I mean we are fine. A couple of more
minutes. Are you guys okay? Sorry.
What did this I feel we have,
um, it's just, we should,
I mean we stream and we record so,
so even if people watch it later,
you want people to have
uncomfortable discussions about
race. But for some of us,
that discomfort is because
these discussions have a
nontrivial probability to be
quite literary career ending.
How can we have these discussions safely?
I have to tell you, this is one
where I understand the trepidation.
I think that my profile and
opportunity,
the opportunities that I have in life had
been magnified by my willingness to go
out on a limb. People told me
not to have this discussion,
that it would be a career ender for me.
And yet having this discussion has allowed
me to be invited to be here and one
of the greatest companies in the
world to sit and talk to you.
And so I see it a little bit differently,
but I know it takes a
tremendous amount of bravery,
which is why a lot of my speeches
right now are about being brave.
I talk about this article that I read
about a woman who every single day told
her daughter to be brave when she went
to college. All of her letter she signed,
be brave, not, I love you.
Be Brave because she wanted
that to be the message to her.
And that's what I tell Everest.
Be Brave her, my George,
the other don't tell the Everest she was
silly. She said, I'm not silly. I'm brave.
And I said,
that's exactly what I want her to feel,
but this is going to take bravery.
And what I tell about tell people
who says it could be, you know,
you lose your job,
your career,
you have to have confidence to
believe you can get another job.
You just have to have that confidence.
I know that sounds really
cavalier and people say, Oh,
you can see that sitting where you are
now. I have always believed in my ability.
If I did excellent work,
excellent,
killed it every single
day I would be wanted.
And I believe that to this day.
And if I can't get the benefit of the
doubt for talking about something that I
think is important,
I think that is what is killing us.
Every one is in these rooms. And
they're not saying it. You know,
people keep telling me
what is happening to them.
My soul being crushed by the nots.
The people who are not speaking up.
And a young woman come to see me the other
day who was busy on being just beyond
stunning, like Mussai
warrior beautiful. You know,
literally she was six feet tall,
chocolate brown,
unbelievably beautiful,
had just graduated from college,
works in this um,
company that's very big
company that you would know.
And she said that her boss
keeps calling her cookie.
Um,
who was the woman from empire cookie?
What's your last name? Lions. She goes, he
goes, her cookie Lyons. So was a cookie.
Lions come here, Cookie Lyons do this,
cause their lines. So she finally,
she came to see me to say,
what do I do?
She's 22.
I am in shock,
right? And she says, there's another
woman who works there who is black.
There are two of us. I'm 22. I said, well,
how long has she been there? She said,
she's been there for eight years.
He calls her cookie Lyons to,
so I said, oh my God. So he
said, her name is Taylor.
So she said, I said, you got
to go and tell him. So she
goes and tell him. She said,
listen, my name is Taylor.
I want to be called Taylor.
I don't want to be called Cookie Lyons.
And he said to her,
what if I call you Taylor Swift?
And she said,
my name is Taylor and no one else on
this whole floor has a different name.
You call them by their name,
I just want to be called Taylor.
So he says, okay, I understand
he stops calling her Taylor.
So the other woman who's eight years
older than her walks in and says,
oh my God,
he stopped calling you cookie Lyons.
Do you think I should
walk in and say something?
So for eight years now, I know
cookie came into existence, what?
Three years ago? I'm assuming there
was something before that maybe,
I shouldn't assume,
but at least for the last three years
he's been calling that other woman who's
been there.
You know,
this woman just graduated from college
this summer and that is what she's
dealing with, not doing her
job being called Cookie Lyons,
who's like a sister girl.
I had got no problem with Cookie Lyons,
but if you saw this woman, I
was like, I don't even get it.
She's like six feet tall. She's, you know,
there's nothing about her that you
can't say like, you look just like,
are you seem like her, you
know, she didn't know why
even are a Gucci trench coat.
And I was like, really? I
just don't get this. So,
but it's the silence of the other
people that allows that to perpetuate.
And people come to me all the time with
things that happen in rooms and I'm like,
it can't just be us
fighting for ourselves.
There were other people
on that floor who knew.
He called her cookie Lyons
and they didn't say anything.
She actually gets the,
the,
the metal here because she's the
youngest most defenseless, no experience,
probably most afraid. But she had
the foresight to say, help me,
what do I do?
And I was like,
go stand up for yourself and if this
does not work out, I told her, I said,
you can roll yourself right into here
at Ariel and I will make a place for you
and you will be a superstar here.
So wow. So, um, let me say one thing
here, just from my perspective.
I'll give you a pledge here.
If anybody ever at Google cause worry
about speaking out about race or fields,
they have a negative
career impact from that.
Tell me all sorted for you.
You should not ever,
ever feel in such a position.
Feel free to contact me.
And I think from the other part
of the story, also important.
If you are in a situation where
you observe behavior like this,
I feel if you're not black,
if you're not a minority,
it is your responsibility to
observe, learn, understand,
speak out.
And if you're not being he heard about it,
feel free to contact me at any point in
time. I will engage. We'll, we'll sort it.
So let me just give you one example of
this. At Princeton we an honor code.
So some of you had this, so we,
every time we sent to take a task,
the honor code was on the front.
You signed,
then you broke the seal and the Honor
Code said if you cheated or you saw
someone cheat and took, didn't turn
the men, yes you were accountable.
You could have the same repercussions for
not turning them in. It's interesting.
If we could adopt an honor
code around these issues.
And so we're actually going to take it
upon ourselves that when we actually see
this injustice, yes, we're
going to call it out. Yes,
we're going to live within the honor of
having this fair and honorable society.
We have to look at it exactly right.
We're used to that.
Many of us have already lived with honor
code. Yes, we have. We have to learn.
We have to understand this better.
Part of the reason why we're having
this discussion here. Right. So, uh, so,
so people that are,
um,
that actually have a non
diverse background understand
those issues better and
that they own,
because only if you know,
you can realize what it means and only
then you can actually go ahead and,
and speak out and you actually,
you have to speak out.
Like I fundamentally believe you have
to speak up. Speak Up, speak out. Yeah.
We have one more live question that's,
go ahead
melody. I love your voice. Thank you
for being here. Speaking of jobs,
have you considered running for president?
No, I haven't considered
that. I, uh, you know, no, I,
I actually, you know, there are
moments now that I have to say I'm,
we all have to do something.
You know,
we all have a role and I'm
taking mine very seriously.
So on the phone on the way here,
I was on the car for two hours.
I was on the phone with planned
parenthood's Cecile Richards.
I was on the phone with
someone representing the head
of the Naacp and the legal
defense fund.
Those are my three calls on the way here
about mobilization and what we will do.
So I plan on, you know,
rising to the occasion and,
and hopefully giving all that I've
got doing everything that I can.
I don't think I'm the right person
for Washington, but I do think, um,
I have a lot of hope that there's someone
here or someone else that we can all
get behind and help change the world
and make it what we want it to be.
The one thing I am hopeful despite being
disappointed and discouraged in some
ways and again,
being very cognizant of other people
who have different of opinion and
respecting those opinions
and the other side. Um, I'm,
I am going to push for the light
as opposed to the darkness.
I'm going to fight for
light. Yup. Thank you.
I think you could be right though
about the office being there.
Thank you. Should we just finish off
with the two live questions please?
It's a little tall. Hi. Hi.
I've looked up to for a really long time
because they feel like you're amazing
at succeeding environments that
aren't necessarily built for you.
Like I read your essay
in Sheryl Sandberg's book
about going to like a mostly
white, proper twice school,
like going to Princeton.
I'm working in finance and
that's something that I
could personally relate to.
Going to a private boarding
school, it was mostly white, um,
and studying econ and math at
Harvard and like working in tech. Um,
but I think the differences are you've
been in one job since you graduated
college. It's very rare. Um,
you've also kind of achieved a lot of
professional success before you've settled
out in marriage and having kids.
Like do you have any advice
for millennials who are
kind of navigating places
that aren't necessarily built for them
but are also having to adjust like,
you know, seven jobs in a
lifetime and um, you know,
like the career clock in your biological
clock not necessarily be in sync.
My major advices, um,
what I think is just true,
if you follow your passion,
you're going to be successful no matter
what because one, you'll be happy. Um,
and I think happiness is really important.
You can't do anything.
Well if you're not happy, you can't be
a good parent, good spouse, girlfriend,
boyfriend.
You can't be a good coworker.
Happiness is important and that
doesn't mean euphoria everyday,
but a basic sense of peace.
And for some of us,
especially type A, and especially
people are hard on ourselves,
we don't give each other
give ourselves a break.
And so the pursuit of happiness as
we have it written obviously in our
declaration of independence is
something that is, um, challenging.
So pursuing happiness. I do think is
important as a pursuit of anything else.
I also think my big advice is to
millennials is stand up for you what you
believe in.
Do not back down.
And that doesn't mean you have to do it
with a fist in the air or um, you know,
with,
with the,
with the aggression you can
do it with grace and um,
I cannot be talked out of what I believe
that that doesn't mean like in my core
values,
you cannot me that racism will
ever be a path to something good.
You cannot convince me that excluding
people is ever leads to a better outcome.
You cannot convince me of that.
I will not be moved.
I will not compromise that point of view.
And so as a result of that,
I'm going to do everything I can to
keep pressing those perspectives.
And I think if any,
any issue I have with some
of the millennials that
I've had the opportunity to
work up close with, don't be compliance.
You know, just you know, you were,
you were taught. Sometimes winning
is the path of least resistance.
And I think this is now more than ever,
or your voice and you know, being,
being willing to put
yourself in harm's way.
It's like the question of losing a job.
I know it sounds like I'm being flip.
I've often asked myself, do I belong here?
Should I walk out? Nothing is worth us.
And you know, I think that, you know,
just really pushing yourself to understand
that sometimes certain things are
just going to have to walk away. If
you really, really, really believe it,
you've got to stand up for
something. So, you know, I, I would,
I went to this program at
the Aspen Institute, the
Henry Crown fellows program,
and we were in these small leadership
groups, 20 people and skip battle,
who's this amazing guy and known
in Silicon Valley was my moderator.
I have so much respect
and admiration for him.
And one day we were in the
room and he said to me, melody,
I know you will do good. I was
like, 30 years old. He goes,
but will you stand in harm's way? Will
you put yourself in harm's way? He's like,
you could go through your whole life
just doing the easy path and feeling good
about yourself and patting
yourself on the bat.
But when you allow yourself to be hurt,
will you allow yourself to
have a tremendous setback
because you stood up for
what you believed.
And that forced me to really think about
the path of least resistance and saying
versus believing that I will
allow myself to be harmed.
And then I started to think about people
like John Lewis Standing on the Edmund
Pettus bridge.
And I start to think,
I literally cannot even say
this without calling up saying,
could I have that kind of courage?
And I think this is the moment
we're standing in right now.
We have to have that John Lewis courage,
that Martin Luther King, courage,
that dog's turned on. Teenagers,
fire hoses turned on people courage.
Because I think that if we were
standing there, I was standing there,
I think I would run. And now
I'm telling myself, stand.
So millennials, you've got so
much power and control. Use it.
Last question. Hi Melody. Um,
I was actually watching via live
stream and then I realized, well,
I might as well just come and see you.
And you said instead of
just through the computer.
And so as a Latina and as someone that
has had to exercise my muscle of bravery
all year at Google,
it's just thank you.
Thank you for reminding me.
Like even this week I had to be
very brave and I was very scared.
And so I help lead our efforts
for Latinos here at Google and,
and really like this, the
past two weeks, I just,
there's so much more that we can do as
Googlers for our Googlers, but our users.
And so I want to know like, what do you
think we can do as Googlers for our, our,
our family of Googlers,
for our families as Googlers
and for our users. Because,
you know, we're, we're really trying
to, to figure this out, um, with,
with everyone.
And so the good thing is that the
intention is there and that will lead to a
good outcome. The one thing I should
say, you can't be brave without fear.
So just always understand that
it's a necessary ingredient,
ingredient to courage and bravery is
fear. It's overcoming it. You know, it's,
it's not the absence of fear.
It's overcoming the fear
that leads you to be brave.
So we all just have to
understand that that's a
vulnerability, but an honesty. Um,
the other thing in terms of
what I think you all can do,
you have the most magnificent voices and
you have the most magnificent platform,
probably one of the best
in the entire world.
And when I'm saying use
that power for good,
I do think you have unique
opportunities to do so. And to me,
I think your opportunity
is to preach tolerance.
It's not about one idea
being right or wrong.
It's been tolerant of
ideas that are different.
And that's where it seems
like our conversations have
really broken down in our
society. Respecting someone's
right to have a different opinion.
And that's why I said at Ariel,
it's hard to do. You know,
in the different Scott pages book,
he said if you were in a meeting and you
find yourself violent leak disagreeing
with a colleague,
you just stand up and clap because you're
going to have a better outcome just
from that disagreement.
And so I think the idea that
you can use this platform for,
of tolerance and use these voices,
which are magnificent,
as I've said multiple times now,
because I really think they are,
you are so unique, so educated, so bold.
You are innovative. You've done something
that has never been done before.
You show growth that
we've never seen before.
You've created an environment that I
literally, I could just move in, you know,
literally, um, what do you need
here? It's up for like a toothbrush,
but I'm sure those are in the bathroom,
right? So, you know, bottom line, I mean,
I think that there's something so special
here to galvanize that the way you've
galvanized it with this great,
tremendous,
never before seen corporate success can
be galvanized into greatness globally
with this voice and you representing
Latinos, um, is wonderful.
And you knowing them,
knowing the responsibility you have,
you have a responsibility. Own this.
It's not about Google, it's about you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you everybody for coming.
Thank you so much.